ornithologists are helpful folk and when
they name a bird the sociable weaver you
can tell that it's going to be a social
creature and one that likes to weave
large nests only the size of sparrows
these birds can build enormous nests
reaching 10 feet tall but lest you think
that we're doing a pleasant little video
about nest building social birds nope
let's meet our antagonist of the story
the 5-foot long cape cobra for whom this
bird's nest is practically a buffet the
cape cobra has some of the most powerful
venom on the continent of africa
paralyzing its victims breathing until
death this is getting dark the bird's
line their nests with sharp straw to
keep the snakes out but determined
Cobras Kennett straw they they use straw
did they not read The Three Little Pigs
straw is not an effective deterrent
against determined predators unable to
save their hatchlings the birds must
save themselves stakes can eat around
70% of their offspring guys this is grim
I honestly thought that the script is
going to be about these cool nests that
the birds of building but now just this
is this carnage satisfied the Cobra
leaves the nest the birds are now safe
to return and survey the damage and I am
just going to go grab a bunch of kitties
and curl up into a ball and
cry
[Music]